pero sobre esto
pedía una discusión y una denuncia en
colombia desde hace muchísimos años es
la fiscalía le entregó a la web una
lista de 8.000 casos y el centro
nacional de memoria histórica documentó
más de 24.000 casos en colombia se
estableció desde el año 97 cuando
hicimos el llamado mandato por la paz
que era completamente prohibido para el
estado y por supuesto para cualquiera es
el reclutamiento de menores de 18 años
en esta lista de 18 mil el 68 por ciento
incluso son menores de 15 años según lo
que ha dicho la gente yo creo que es muy
importante en investigaciones está
demostrando seriedad avance en los
procedimientos de justicia transicional
y al mismo tiempo están compareciendo
los ex combatientes de las farc a hacer
honor a la verdad yo creo que eso es un
gran mensaje para la sociedad y también
para quienes se mantienen en armas tanto
paramilitares como insurgentes como
disidentes y demás para tengan en cuenta
de que la humanidad no tolera esto el
protocolo facultativo ha probado
internacionalmente clasificado por
colombia en 2005 estableció toda
prohibición en condiciones internos per
de tratamiento de menores de 18 años
usted toca un tema muy importante y es
que le pregunto la importancia que tiene
el informe de esta fricción especial
para la paz en los objetivos de búsqueda
de la verdad y también reparación para
las víctimas en colombia
la verdad que es impresionante el dolor
de la familia buscando a sus familiares
yo presencié cuando se estaba haciendo
el congreso del alfar acogiendo los
acuerdos de paz presencia de familiares
haciendo fila buscando a sus hijos a sus
hijas que de niños habían sido
incorporados a las guerrillas por
diferente manera de manera forzada o
porque se habían alistado y algunos de
ellos desaparecidos la unidad de
búsqueda de personas desaparecidas ya
tiene un listado provisional de varios
centenares de menores de 18 años es un
dolor para colombia es un punto aclarar
pero sobre todo es un asunto de no
repetición la verdad y la no repetición
son fundamentales y no solamente para
esclarecer el pasado y darle
satisfacción a las víctimas sino para
que se supere una situación de violencia
atroz contra las familias campesinas en
su gran mayoría en colombia
usted también hablaba de un tema de
violencia sexual desaparición forzada
homicidio tortura esto corresponde a
crímenes internacionales y además cuáles
van a ser las consecuencias para la
gente que estos actos y la jurisdicción
especial para la paz tiene unos unos
unas condiciones precisamente por eso es
una justicia restaurativa que le da una
importancia mayor a la verdad y en
consideración al esclarecimiento el
proceso judicial
que lleve a la verdad se tienen
beneficios
penales disminución de penas hay unos
topes que hacen diferencia con la
justicia ordinaria pero yo creo que más
importante que todo este procedimiento
punitivo o judicial lo más importante es
la sanación para la sociedad es la
reparación a las víctimas y un mensaje
de que esto no puede volver a ocurrir en
la sociedad colombiana señor gonzález
gracias por su tiempo y por estar aquí
con nosotros en frente tipo de analizar
este complejo y el groso panorama en
colombia